what did you feel when you first realize
that moment that Breaking Bad was
breaking bad that people had that
reaction to it well I felt it was great
it was sort of my third rise to fame so
I and but the first thing that I felt
was that I'm finally able to sort of
deal with it position it in my life as
it should be
it feels I'm very comfortable in my own
skin I'm comfortable with people it's
finding that space that is out of the
ego space that allows you just to be you
sometimes it makes me laugh and it's
quite funny and other times I'm thinking
wow how crazy is this that people don't
even really know my name and then I get
a little angry behind that but Gus is
more famous than I am it's such a great
thing you know I mean here's the guy who
created every motion every part of this
character yet people know his name and
don't know mine hahaha it's like you
can't win for losing yeah so so I
reminds me to be madly in love with the
work and the work only and then I come
here to give back to the fans who so
want to have that personal experience
it's nice sure they really appreciate it
and know they have done you've been cues
around the block today to see you you
talked about you know you obviously
being the man behind the creation of Gus
fring how did you go about getting under
the skin of that character and creating
him to be the character that we all
loved to watch on that show well I
should really correct myself I can't
take full and complete responsibility
because the character was written Vince
Gilligan wrote a character who was
basically a glorified waiter and that's
all he knew he knew one thing that he
wrote that was so profound for me that
was my clue was hiding in plain sight
and when I started to think about that
there was one episode of Gus written and
a template for a second where he would
be involved in it but that those words
hiding in plain sight made me really
think and inspired me and when I was
asked to come back for a second episode
I should also say I was a waiter in my
life and you know it's interesting to
wait on people in many ways the fans
today wait on me they want my autograph
but when I'm waiting on people I'm
showing my best face I'm showing that
best side of myself so
I can you know get a good tip so I can
keep my job all those things that I may
not be feeling in the moment when I'm
asking them is everything to your
satisfaction would you like a refill you
I may not really feel like that and when
I started to think about gossin this guy
I thought this is my route in to really
thinking about someone that we all might
know who is doing something quite
different than what he is projecting
what he's putting forth and that was the
key for me and that was the beginning
that was the beginning of a plethora of
ideas that allowed me to really be a
citizen of our society someone who gives
to the fun-run someone who you know
gives at the hospital
but someone who is hiding something and
he's yet a businessman he's hiding
something and I thought how many people
do we know in our lives who were hiding
something
definitely very scary isn't it I mean
you mentioned of course Vince Gilligan
there he created the show I mean how
much better how much input did you get
as the show went on into that character
of Gus well this is the way I like to
put it I was so inspired by the writing
of Vince and his writers and the one
line hiding in plain sight that I
brought forth what I wanted to give it
and those the very first episode before
I got off the plane as the plane was
landing my phone was ringing saying
would you come back so what I did
inspired Vince and I like to look at it
that way because then he was inspired to
write more and deepen things and then we
had a conversation and I was able to
tell him that I wanted to be a part of a
filmmaking family but I felt that this
character was quintessential not only to
his show but also to the way we look at
people who are around us in life and I
wanted to create a gentleman who was
very meticulous and very methodical but
yet was more of an observer but yet
underneath it all he wanted to help
people become their best selves why
would anyone cultivate chemist's
directly I put them through college and
make an agreement for them to cook for
him he's very meticulous and wanted the
highest quality of the product he was
about to produce very few people are
like that we mass-produce things we
throw crap against the wall we hope it
sticks and we hope that our ideas will
make a million
when they're half-baked this guy thinks
things out and it was a really great
great way to look at how we follow
through in terms of what we want for our
success in life and I thought people
would really be interested in what I had
to lend to this character and of course
you're working with another character in
a show who's all super factious isn't he
and Bryan Cranston's character
Heisenberg his pseudonym is I mean he's
a perfectionist cuz he wants to get that
as pure as possible as well doesn't he I
mean what was it like working with him
as an actor I love Bryan I think when I
work with Bryan I think of a master
actor and I think we make great music
together and I know that that's what
Vince and the producers at AMC saw we
had fireworks together you know there's
there's two ways to do it actors who are
with actors who are as strong as they
are sometimes fight and vie for position
so that they're trying to one-up each
other there are the actors who feel that
they may be weaker than their scene
partner so then they shrink and they're
actors who just stay in the moment and
don't lose their footing and that's who
Bryan is he didn't he knew who he was as
Walter White I knew what I was trying to
create as Gustavo Fring there was no
issue for me to try to top him or him to
top me we just knew our ground and we
made music and that's when the music is
the best
so I adore him as an actor and as a
human being and I feel like the music we
made together with some of the sweetest
music I've ever made with any scene
partner ever
fantastic we certainly enjoyed watching
I mean it was a shame to show ever had
to come to an end but it was great that
it went out on such a high I think and
of course now we've had news that
there's going to be a prequel with
better call Saul I mean what did you
think when you heard about that I was
jealous what did I think because then I
heard months later that it was either at
the better call Saul or it was the rise
of Gus and because Vince had already
fleshed out with Bob who I adore another
great human being great actor great
comic Odenkirk that they had already
talked about doing a spin-off for Saul
because that would be fun
and so yeah the first reaction was
[ __ ]
you know or shite why why not me but you
know I believe now that there's nothing
that's for you if it's for you it'll be
for you
however Vince did they did come to me
and say would you make an appearance and
part of me says that I would love to but
I don't want to dilute what I've already
done is Gus if Gus is dead and gone let
him be gone because he will be legendary
be known far beyond my days you'll know
Gus Gustavo Fring however I do think
that there is room for me if I were to
appear on Saul I would love for it to be
more than one episode maybe a couple of
episodes and then to spin it off into
the rise of Gus for a limited thirteen
episodes so I've sort of put it out
there put it out there with you guys and
put it out there with Vince that that
might be something for that I would be
really interested in pursuing because
because of the fans so many people and
because I feel like there is a
background of Gus that I have not even
been able to show and would love to be
able to portray I mean if you could do
that and we God we would love to see you
do that and what would you like to
happen for Gus what would you like that
rise to involve I would like for us to
see the part of him in Chile that we
don't know the part of his dedication to
the young chemist we saw a piece of it
with Max the part of his dedication to
to his family I have a great sense that
Gus is from an untouchable family and
that he went the wrong way so I'd love
to see how he dealt with his family how
he disposed of them or allowed them to
see him in this new light in a way it's
you know that the Osama bin Laden story
you know the rogue son who went away and
and all the the stuff that went on with
Osama with it the you know he supposedly
was addicted to drugs he supposedly went
against a very rich family and had his
own ideas this is partly Gustavo as well
Gustavo just turned out to be a
gentleman so I would love to see how
that all took place it would be quite
amazing I think he had ties to the
military I think you know a revenge ever
ever
eventually it revenge was his undoing
but I think all these things you know
lend to the makeup of the man I know he
was married and had children you know
which we didn't show on the show there
was all this you know people talking
about was he gay was a relationship with
Max but I happen to believe that Gus was
a very upstanding family man and knew
how to raise children
we saw none of that you know you saw it
in Walters life I would love to be able
to capture some of it in Gus's life and
to see the brutality that went into the
making of this extremely calm fastidious
and graceful gentleman I mean if you
could have any actors or actresses in
that show because let's make that happen
over here would you like to be acting
within it
I don't know certainly to begin it would
be great to see Bob and I have no idea
about anyone else that present to be
honest with you you've thrown me for a
little bit of a loop I would want actors
who were deeply rooted in establishing
character and committed to great writing
would be all I would ask for but I think
there'd be some a wide variety of
choices to be a part of that that I
would I would love to Sophie will be
clamoring to be part of it let's talk a
little bit about revolution I mean it's
another show we've really enjoyed and
we're very sad to say that it hasn't
it's not gonna be continuing I mean what
did you feel when you when you heard
that new well I was sad you know I do
feel like many parts of revolution had
so much potential and I feel really
great about Eric Kripke who created the
show and JJ Abrams who co-produced the
show I was saddened because I feel like
that I was really moving toward the the
continuation of creating such a great
character in Tom Neville I mean a guy
who really came from nothing and was
beaten down and learned to be a survivor
and learn to be a killer and a leader
very complicated human being and I had
more to to say in that regard I I do I
do think that an ensemble show and a
network show has to have so many
elements that please so many different
people across the board that it's much
more difficult to be more fine-tuned
about things and to be broad is to
to have a little comedy and have to have
some science and all these things which
is a lot to get into 42 minutes of
television so they we did our best and I
think we did a great job I certainly
feel like I in a way with many of the
shows I've done lately I've sort of
dodged the bullet I've been a part of
one of the best shows ever on television
and then in creating revolution I had
such a great storyline with Kim Raver
who was over in London doing 24 I mean
we had sparks between us you know then I
was able to do you know ride a horse and
be that action hero of some note and I
feel like it's all practice for the big
ones so I think there's still yet
another role that might be have some of
the elements of Tom Neville I don't
think I'm running out of ideas I think
tom was a just a loose cannon and but so
passionate and did all of his own dirty
work made him very different than Gus
but I have more to offer in that arena I
don't know if I could ever go back and
do it you know I I think I'll wait till
later years to play a lawyer and being a
procedural show because I've had so much
fun with the revolution I mean look I
ride and I always liked all the cowboys
when we were shooting down in Austin and
shooting down and Wilmington beforehand
with you know I walk up to the force and
I would let him smell me and I touched
the horse's head and I'd stand there and
just rub the horse they'd look at me and
they go do you ride you know cuz these
guys are hardcore and I said yeah right
a little bit
I can still learn some things and I get
on the horse and they would look at me
and I'd control the horse very gently
and they'd go oh oh you're good they go
on not as good as you are but I can
handle the horse you know
so I love that stuff and to be hey look
I am an outdoors guy who loves to act I
ski I ride motorcycles I'm cycle so to
be on a show like revolution where I'm
outside ten hours a day doing my work is
is a blessing and I hope that maybe
another network will pick it up and if
not I'll have the opportunity to do
something like that again we hope so too
either both of those I mean you
mentioned JJ Abrams over courses behind
his company bad robots I was on
producers of revolution and of course
he's doing Star Wars Episode seven which
is just sort of shooting I mean what did
you think when you heard the news that
he was on board for that and why do you
think he'll be a great director
serious well I think JJ is a very astute
director with new ideas I think he's
been trained by the best and surrounded
himself with the best to work with his
company bad robot is absolutely amazing
in terms of people are really human
there so you know that comes from the
top and I like that a lot when you see a
showrunner whose folks who work for them
are happy that means he's doing
something right he is the fearless
leader who has compassion and kindness
and grace so when I first heard he was
doing Star Wars my first one I'm an
actor so I think of myself uh you know
can I be in it what's in it for me and
so I did mention it to JJ and he said
that'd be interesting it might be
something interesting there but I
haven't gotten the call and that is okay
I still adore him and I love what he
does and I think he is the perfect
person to take over that franchise and
we'll make it work and make it exciting
and do something different no we have to
stir the pot and when you're doing
something that's been done so many times
before you want to have someone who has
new ideas and can enhance and and do
something new with what we've already
seen is a real talent and I mean it's
great to see him mixing up things as you
say and bringing in new young people
like brilliant British actor called John
boyega you know Adam driver call some
girls and Andy Serkis is in there as
well as well as the people who we know
from that world originally like Harrison
Ford and Carrie Fisher - I think it's
brilliant the way he's mixed it up I
really loved that I just missed him in
Dubai I was there for signing and he was
there looking for locations then I had
just missed him in London and I loved
that he was seeing actors from all over
the world because this is where our
world is coming we're a melting pot of
people who understand each other from
across the sea and otherwise and I think
it's brilliant of him to be targeting a
world market with his creativity he so
deserves to be successful now you said
that you would have loved to been in
episode 7 but there's still two more to
come as episode 8 and 9 as well so would
you like to be in Star Wars and if you
could be installed was what kind of
character would you like to be well I'd
like to play a leader you know I would
really like to play a leader who knows
what he's doing but has some
vulnerability underneath it so yeah I
put it out there that
you know the eight and nine would be
absolutely wonderful for me to be and I
know there was a military officer in
seven probably a smaller part but I'm
ready for the big huge ones and I would
only want to work with JJ in in that
regard so hey JJ I'm here still and I
love you and of course there's also Star
Trek which the third one JJ is not
directing but Roberto Orci who's the
writer of the other ones is would you be
up for a role in Star Trek yeah you know
I like the sci-fi world it's a world
that is now coming into its own although
it's being recreated all over again and
I think it's important to have some very
very good actors who can deal with the
technological advances that we have in
film many times you're acting with
nobody there and years ago I did a film
with Francis Ford Coppola was called
Cotton Club and you know we acted with
green screen and there was no furniture
we had to just sort of you know it's
really that pantomime play of the
children play and that is so reminiscent
of what we do in movies today and I love
the technology of film and I'd love to
be involved in something like that again
what would you like to say to the fans
out there of yours that are watching
this video right now you know I really
like to say thank you for supporting me
you know I come to these Comic Cons
because I think that the fans who are so
loyal to me I'd love to be able to give
them something a piece of myself back to
them and and so all those Breaking Bad
fans who expect me to be like that all
the time they're always surprised when
they see this great smile I want to let
them know who I am and how much I love
them for supporting me and I love what I
do so I believe that what you think
grows what you think in here grows and
it grows in a way that if you do
something every day if you do something
today to determine your tomorrow it'll
come true because that's what dreams are
dreams are thoughts that are worked on
and put into the universe and practiced
and believed in and then they can come
true
and I certainly have had my dream come
true because I don't work a day in my
life because I love what I do
beautiful points finish on thank you so
much for speaking to us today
pleasure Jan thank you for having me